the united nations is hosting a donor
conference for afghanistan in geneva
later today the aim is to raise more
than half a billion euros the u.n says
that money is desperately needed to
avert a humanitarian crisis in
afghanistan following the taliban
takeover half of the population that's
around 18 million people are dependent
on foreign aid and that number might
grow
a flimsy tent on a kabul street is all
this family have to call home
to feed hungry mouths people here are
reliant on handouts
for now a local ngo has stepped in to
help
but its founder says that many other
support services have disappeared in the
wake of the taliban takeover
so many children so many families
breastfeeding children pregnant women
they all come and sat on the ground
without nothing so complete disaster
complete disaster i gone every day bring
them bread water
milk for the children and take care of
them while there is none organization
exists to support them because
everybody's left afghanistan
many of the people left behind are
facing a desperate situation the un says
more than half a million have been
internally displaced this year
forced from their homes as the taliban
swept across the country
some were fleeing another menace
drought
here in the northwest province of badges
the animals are sick and the crops have
dried out
across the country the drought has
exacerbated existing food shortages
millions are now at risk of starvation
prompting the un to issue a stark
warning
basic services in afghanistan are
collapsing and food and other
life-saving aid is about to run out
aid organizations and governments are
scrambling to fill the gap this flight
from pakistan brought flour cooking oil
and emergency medical supplies
but much more is needed to avert
catastrophe for millions of vulnerable
afghans
well mary ellen mccrory joins us now
from kabul she's the world food
programme's country director for
afghanistan mary ellen
how dire is the situation
yeah uh good morning yeah the the
situation is becoming incredibly
desperate uh you know we had the drought
uh already before the the events of the
15th of august
already 14 million people uh in severe
hunger and since the 15th of august we
just have seen the situation you know
magnify in in in terms of of what's
happening before us our recent surveys
have shown that you know 61
of people are are reducing their food
consumption already three and four
afghan families don't have enough to eat
they're borrowing
food uh they're foregoing meals they're
not you know they're forgoing more
nutritious food to to buy cheaper food
so situation is really becoming
incredibly incredibly difficult
and we just have a catastrophe unfolding
before our eyes
as we've heard in the report that many
aid organizations have
left the country
that of course might be a big factor but
also the takeover of the taliban how has
that directly impacted on the supply of
food to the afghan people
yeah yeah many of the agencies are still
here wfp is here in the ground but i
think one of the big factors since uh
august the 15th is is you know the
impact on the on budget support the
impact on the overseas uh assistance
that money that comes in to keep basic
services running you know the basic
services the healthy education are at
imminent closure imminent collapse
also uh you know people are unable to
access cash when i go out around the
city now i see shops boarded up i see
long long queues at the bank trying to
take out just 300
and i see the market stalls much much
less produce on the market stalls and
the silence around the market the
silence around the bustle of shopping is
is very evident
winter is approaching what do you need
now from the international community
uh we need funding now a wfp needs 200
million dollars now we need to get food
into the country before the winter
approaches as you know in afghanistan
many of the roads many of the
communities are cut off during the snow
during the very harsh winters as this
country gets so we're racing against the
clock we're racing against winter to
stave off uh hunger from the drought and
hunger from the economic crisis
well the donor conference for
afghanistan's getting underway in geneva
today we've heard that
earlier how confident are you uh that
enough money will be given
i i'm hoping that the the you know the
international community you know will
will
you know reach into their pockets and
support afghanistan at this time uh
um it's it's it's critical uh for our
shared humanity it's critical for the
humanitarian effort that in their
greatest time of need that the
international community stands alongside
the women and children and men of
afghanistan whose lives have been
upended through no fault of their own
marielle mccarty there from the world
food programme in kabul thank you very
much
thank you